hey everyone is Sears register nurse RN
calm and in this video I want to
demonstrate for you how to spike an IV
bag and prime the tubing so what does I
can prime me biking bag means that we
are going to use the spike from the
tubing to penetrate the bag so we can
withdraw the solution so it can go into
the patient's bloodstream and priming IV
tubing means that we're going to take
the solution and put it through our line
to remove any air because we don't want
to inject air into a patient's
bloodstream because it can cause an air
embolism so as a nurse you are going to
be doing this all the time this is
standard care so if you are a student or
a new nurse I really recommend that you
get familiar with this skill and
practice as much as you can so the whole
goal of IV therapy is to take this bag
of solution may just be basic normal
saline or a medication like heparin and
we want to get this into the patient's
bloodstream so it'll use tubing and it
will go through that tubing your pump
will regulate it and then it will go
into the patient's bloodstream so that
is a route of how we give medication
okay first what you want to do is you
want to perform hand hygiene because
this skill requires that you use aseptic
technique and we want to be very careful
not to contaminate our bags or our IV
tubing because we could cause the
patient and infection and next what you
want to do is you want to confirm that
you have the right solution so you look
at your visitors order look at your bag
make sure it matches up and make sure
that you have the right patient next
you'll want to get some IV tubing and
every facility on different types of
tubing depending on their supplier so
get familiar with what you have but how
you spiked a bag and prime the tubing
they all tend to work the same and also
make sure that your bag
comes with a label so you can label the
tubing it's usually found sometimes
staple to the bag inside the bag or you
may have to pick it up in an alcove
where supply pizza but you will want
this because it's very important that
you label your two
me whenever you initiate new tubing
because it expired and here are some key
points you wants to remember and with
continuous tubing such that you're going
to use if you're not using it to
administer blood blood products or fat
emulsions like t pn or lipids the CDC
recommends that you change the frequency
of the tubing every 96 hours which is
four days however hospitals have their
own protocols based on the CDC's
protocol it's usually anywhere from
seventy two hours to 96 hours most of
the places I work is 72 hours so every
three days now say you were going to be
starting blood or a blood product or TPN
or lipids and the CDC recommends that
you change the tubing every 24 hours and
that tends to be feeders here for
hospitals so always keep that in mind
and the very first thing what I like to
do so I don't forget to label my to me
because it's really important because if
another nurse comes in behind you taking
over patient care they need to know when
that tubing expires if do they need to
change it or they just don't have to
throw the whole thing away because
they're unsure and that waste supplies
so I like to label my little label first
and so I don't forget because if I get
really busy may get lost in the
patient's bed fall on the floor and then
I'll completely forget okay first we're
going to fill out the start day and this
is when you initiated it so go ahead and
fill that part out so we're going to
march 10th 2017 and HR means hour and
that's the time that you started it and
this needs to be written in military
time so we're going to put 0 8 4 5 4
8:45 in the morning and then the discard
day is when and this is according to
your hospital protocol whenever they say
that you need to change it out so we'll
say it 72 hours so we'll need to discard
this on 313 2017 and the hour will match
up and whenever we start it so 0 8 45
and then put your initials now what we
want to do is we want to open our tubing
so just tear it open and take our tubing
out and you want to unkink the tubing
and remove
any pace that's keeping the tubing
together and what I like to do is I like
to go ahead and apply my label to the
tubing so I don't forget and the best
place to do this is right below this
drip chamber so whenever it's hanging up
there on the pole everyone can see it
and it's easy to find you'll have to
look down or around it's just completely
right there so we have it labeled now
with one of the parts of the IV tubing
at the top underneath this cap is where
you have the spike this part will go
inside the bag to penetrate it so we can
withdraw the fluid and you don't want to
touch when this cap off that spike
because you will contaminate the tubing
and you'll need to start all over
below that this area right here is the
drip chamber we will squeeze that when
we start to allow the fluid to drop in
there so we can get it to go through the
line and as we go down we have these
little access ports that is used to
administer medications any IV pushes and
as we go down through our tubing this
part right here for this particular
tubing that is for an IV pump and this
acts as a key when it goes into the pump
and you can set your rate and this part
right here get really familiar with that
because you will be using that a lot
it's the roller clamp you just roll this
part of the plant to turn it off and
we're going to keep it in the off
position right now so whenever you
always start turn it off because when we
penetrates this bag we don't want all
these fluids rushing out on us we want
to be able to control it so it's in the
off position right now and then this
part right here is the part that will
screw onto the patient's IV central line
whatever they have and we'll remove that
blue cap and whenever remove the cap we
want to be really careful not to touch
the inside of that part of the part of
that because and we can contaminate it
now what we're going to do is we're
going to spike the bag and whenever I do
this I like to wear gloves because I
don't want to get contaminated with
whatever type of medications in here
especially if you're going to be giving
nitroglycerin or something like that you
don't want to get that on your hands and
I want to decrease the chances of me
contaminating it myself
oh and what we're going to do is we're
going to put this bike inside the spike
port now you have two ports on your IV
bag you had a medication administration
port which we will not be using use this
port to instill medications into the
fluids a lot of times pharmacy does that
and you have right beside of it the
spiking port so what we're going to do
is we're going to hold the IV bag in our
non-dominant hand then we're going to
pull this stopper off and then we're
going to remove the cap from the tubing
and we're going to be careful not to
contaminate these by touching this and
then we're just going to penetrate the
spike into the spiking port and you
really got a twist to get it in there
you just it's not very easy you just
can't slide it in there you got to
really twist it okay and then we're
going to turn it back and see nothing's
boiling out because we have our clamp or
salt so that's good and then we're going
to hang it on the pole now we're going
to squeeze our drip chamber and we want
the fluid from the bag to enter into
this chamber and to feel where this line
is so we're going to squeeze it you've
got to give it a couple squeezes
sometimes and that's about as much as we
want now you're going to open up the
clamp by turning it to this position and
what's going to happen is that all that
fluid from the drip chamber is going to
drain through your tubing and this is
what's called priming the line because
we want to remove any air from the line
and you will start to see it come out
this area and this blue cap on here
you'll probably have to loosen it a
little bit so the fluid can come out so
let's unclamp a roller clamp and I like
to control the flow a little bit so it's
not all coming out really fast and here
in the second oval we come in and it'll
start to drip out as you can see and you
can let this drip into the sink
wherever you have access to let it drip
and you want to let all the air bubbles
get out you don't want any large air
bubbles in your
I can our tubing is nice and primed now
okay so you always want to double check
your line make sure there's no massive
air bubbles in there so I'm here I just
wanted to demonstrate for you so you can
see what I'm talking about here's the
fluid right here but from here to here
is air we do not one side so you can
flip it a little bit and you need to
refresh your line just to make sure
there's none in there and so it won't go
to the patient so after you have primed
your tubing you're ready to connect your
bag to the IV pump which will control
the rate of how fast your bag will drip
in and you'll connect the tubing to your
patient this little blue cap twist all
and you'll just screw this part in to
your patients access whatever they have
and say that you're not ready to connect
this yet and just make sure that you
keep this part covered just so it
doesn't become contaminated and put your
roller clamp in the off position so your
solution isn't spilling out everywhere
okay so that wraps up how to spike an IV
bag and prime IV tubing thank you so
much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos